في طحن حبات القهوه فن لا يتقنه الا من
اعتادت يده تحضيرها على نغمه طرقات
المهباش هنا من تعد هذا الفن الى اصل
حكايه هذه الاداء وتكوينها التي تعود
بالزمن سنين الى الوراء
هكذا ياخذ الخشب شكله هويته ليحفر في عمق
التاريخ باحثا عن تحفه تورثها عن الاباء
والاجداد السيد سامر فريحات صانع المهباش
واحد من حمل على عاتقه صناعه هذه الاداه
صبر طويل وجهد لا يقف امام متعته في
الحفاظ على ارثا اردنيا بامتياز
اردني
بعشقها بعشق سلامتك
[موسيقى]
المعالم الاردنيه بنحطها كمان حتى نسبه
هويتك اردنيين على صناعه المباشر
مع صوت الشبابه والصوت الربابه وايضا عده
ادوات موسيقيه اخرى
لا يمهل هذا المهباش حبات القهوه الا وقتا
قليلا حتى الانتهاء من طحنها وتجهيزها
بمذاق فريد رغم قسوه الضربات من محافظه
عجلون شمال العاصمه عمان سوها جميل
العربيه